hey luke here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel today i'm going to tell
you everything you need to know about
rocket stoves and i'm going to show you
a couple different ways you can make
your own rocket stove at home real cheap
real easy
a rocket stove is a super efficient
wood-burning stove that allows you to
cook an entire meal with just a handful
of sticks they can be light portable
easy to make but the benefits is that
you don't have to carry any fuel with
you so if you're traveling light or if
you're in a prepper situation these are
really great hey jacob are you gonna
help me with my rocket stove video
yeah
you got a stick yeah okay good
all rocket stoves are basically l-shaped
wood burning stoves that look like this
you drop a bunch of sticks in the
vertical section you catch them on fire
and the heat goes up through the
vertical section like so
and then fresh air and oxygen is drawn
in through the horizontal section and
what makes these so effective and so
efficient is that it concentrates the
heat and sends it upwards to where your
cooking pan
is by using a rocket stove and
concentrating all of that heat you're
going to get a much more efficient burn
and you're going to use that heat much
more effectively so this allows you to
cook and do a lot with just a handful of
sticks one of the simplest rocket stoves
to bake is the dakota fire hole
just go and find yourself a little slope
and excavate out
the basic l shape
of a fire hole
you can do this with your hands or a
stick
doesn't have to be very big and you just
drop in some sticks here
light them on fire
and there you go
the air comes in this way
heat goes out this way
last month we posted a video where me
and my boys dug and slept in an
underground bunker which was basically a
giant dakota fire hole we basically dug
a big hole
and then made the l-shaped fireplace in
the side of the hill and that's the same
technique as the dakota fire hole only
on a much much bigger scale rocket
stoves are so simple there's many
different ways to build them and one of
my favorite is drilling a 90 degree hole
or an l shaped hole in a solid piece of
wood then take some framing nails and
put about four or five framing nails
around the circumference of the wood
round to lay your tea kettle or your
frying pan on top last month when we
were ice fishing in alaska we used this
technique to make a rocket stove that we
brought out onto the ice so that we
could have hot chocolate and something
to warm the kids hands up on
generally speaking you'll get about one
hour of burn time for every inch of
radius you have on the log
if you like that trick but you want a
smaller more portable rocket stove try
using a 4x4 post this eight foot length
was two dollars at the hardware store
all right i'm going to cut off six
inches
all right take your six inch piece of
wood and a one inch drill bit
and drill a hole vertically right in the
dead center
for this demo i'm using a one and a
quarter inch drill bit but i've
successfully used three quarter inch one
inch and one and a quarter inch the
bigger the drill bit though the easier
it is to start the rocket stove
we're gonna gather up some of these
shavings we're just going to dump some
of this shavings in here and you don't
want to block the hole you need
you need to be able to have airflow in
and out
there you go got some smoke coming out
see how the smoke's traveling this
direction always turn the rocket stove
so the mouth is facing into the wind get
as much air going in there as you can
alright i'm gonna set a timer and we're
going to see how long this little 4x4
rocket stove will last
and i'm going to try to boil some water
on my little stove so you need little
spacers to allow the smoke and flames to
escape and you want to put them like so
and line them up so that they're
parallel with the direction of the wind
and then we're just going to lay that
down right there and we've got about
three cups of water in there we're gonna
see how long it takes for that to boil
well we're about five minutes in and the
fire is now self-sustaining the inside
diameter of the hole has caught fire so
i don't need to put any more wood in to
keep this rocket stove going until it's
fully consumed
well this eight foot post cost me two
dollars and i can get 16 rocket stoves
out of this one post so that means each
rocket stove cost me about 12 and a half
cents
not bad
one really nice thing about rocket
stoves they work great in the rain the
pot keeps rain from getting in the
vertical hole and as long as you don't
have rain going inside that hole you're
golden all right we're exactly 21
minutes in and we've got boiling water
and you've got to boil water for a full
one minute to clean it at sea level so
about 22 minutes we should have three
cups of drinking water and you can see
here
we're not quite halfway
consumed
the rocket stove still has a lot of fuel
to give
what you'll find is that the rocket
stove burns faster and hotter the longer
it goes as the hole gets bigger there's
more surface area to burn and that puts
out more flame and that consumes the
wood faster
one nice thing about these uh rocket
stoves is you can pick them up and move
it around and because this one's made
out of wood
i can hold it and not burn myself and
you can see here the bottom hasn't
charred yet so if i had this on a table
it wouldn't ruin the table so i wouldn't
put this inside a tent or put it on your
favorite table or anything but
you can move it around a little bit that
is nice we're at 29 minutes and you can
see here that the front of the rocket
stove is starting to burn the way
through
the top still has a lot of wood left
but we'll see how long it lasts if you
want to you can put out the rocket stove
and save it to use it later just
sprinkle a little water on it try not to
go too heavy-handed because you don't
want to try to light a waterlogged
rocket stove all right we're at 37 and a
half minutes and you can see the front
of the rocket stove is burned all the
way through
and i'm going to go ahead and put the
pot back on the top and we're going to
see how long
it can sit there without that pot
falling over
[Music]
well the pot fell over at almost 60
minutes exactly so that gives you an
hour of cook time on this little 4x4
rocket stove that's more than enough to
cook a nice meal or to boil two big pots
of water each one of these rocket stoves
seems to burn a little bit differently
you want it to burn as evenly as
possible that'll get you more burn time
and how you drill the holes how you feed
the wood which way the wind's blowing
all that kind of affects which side
burns out first now if you want a rocket
stove that's a little bit more permanent
i'm going to show you a great way how to
make a metal rocket stove at home we're
going to make a sheet steel rocket stove
from these hvac t-joints here there's
the four inch one the six inch one and
the eight inch one
the four inch one here is about twelve
dollars and they go on up to price to
about eighteen dollars turning this into
a rocket stove can be as simple or as
complicated as you want depending on how
many bells and whistles you want if you
want to do it the easy way just go ahead
and dump a bunch of sticks right into
the top of the t-joint
so there you go you can just take the
basic t-joint and turn it into a rocket
stove with no construction whatsoever
this little t intersection by itself
works really good as a rocket stove but
there's a few problems first off the
galvanization comes off and that makes
it susceptible to rust additionally it's
kind of tippy the other thing is there's
no way to carry it without a pair of
tongs and there's issues with how do you
cook on it or how do you keep the rain
out of it all of those issues can be
solved really easily so this little cap
you can buy for a few dollars at the
hardware store it goes on to any of
these four inch t units and you can bend
it
to make it flat and then you can put a
kettle or skillet on top of it and it'll
help keep the rain out as well
once you've used the t intersection once
the galvanization will oxidize
and kind of get this powdery look
then you can go and paint it with some
high heat spray paint that's designed
for like stoves and barbecues and stuff
and that'll protect it from rust to make
it look nicer
[Music]
the next thing i'm going to do is put a
handle on this thing so you can
transport it
[Music]
there we go
all right here's my improved
do-it-yourself rocket stove i've got the
same hvac t joint but i've taken a four
inch to six inch adapter and i've done a
really crappy job drilling holes and
cutting these triangles in it which
allow the smoke and air to circulate
through it even when you've got a pot on
top and then here in the bottom i've
poured a couple inches
of grout that's designed for high heat
situations like fireplaces and that
gives it some weight so it no longer
wants to tip over now it's quite sturdy
then i took this little bit of a steel
bar and i made a handle just bent it and
put it in some holes i drilled the side
and came up with this little wood dowel
so now i can pick it up and lift it
around without burning myself
so a couple things about this design
first you want to make sure that the
handle is long enough so that it hits
down low where the mortar is not where
the fire is because otherwise it'll burn
the handle secondly if you put some high
heat cement or mortar down in the bottom
it insulates it so it doesn't get hot
down here and it won't burn whatever
it's sitting on so you can put it on a
park table or a bench or something and
you won't leave a big char mark there i
really like this adapter for cooking
because you can fit a pot on top of it
just like that and it's really sturdy
it's not going to accidentally fall off
like that if you're looking for a
portable durable high quality rocket
stove that you can purchase check out
the kelly kettle and what the kelly
kettle is is a rocket stove with a water
reservoir around the vertical part of
the rocket stove you pour water here at
the top
and that water gets heated up by the
heat that comes through the metal on the
rocket stove there's also this little
attachment that you can put in the top
so that you can cook on top of the
rocket stove as well and in previous
videos i've even cooked scotch eggs on
my kelly kettle they're really versatile
you can cook on them you can boil water
and they're portable high quality and
pretty easy to get a hold of i'll put a
link in the description to where you can
purchase these now if you're a little
bit of a welder and you want a rocket
stove that's very durable and you don't
mind the weight
you can build one using four inch
channel pipe unfortunately i don't have
a welder that can handle this so i can't
demonstrate it here for you today now
i'm going to show you how to build a
rocket stove using just four cinder
blocks
if you don't want to mess with cutting a
cinder block you can buy an h shaped
cinder block or you can just get a
couple pavers and make your own
there we go
very simple rocket stove made out of
four cinder blocks airflow comes in here
combustion happens here heat and exhaust
comes out there and if you want you can
bust out this side and make two burners
and if you don't want to mess with
cutting cinder blocks just use pavers or
bricks and then you can go and build the
same sort of l shape very easily
on all of these rocket stoves you want
the air intake hole pointing upwind so
you get maximum airflow up through the
bottom of the flame now building a
rocket stove out of cinder blocks is
fine it'll last a little while but the
hotter and longer you use this the more
the cinder blocks will start to crumble
and break down and crack you really want
to make a permanent structure you need
to use fire brick
if you want to cook on this thing what
you want to do is take the old pieces
of cinder block
put them right there and then you can
rest your frying pan or your kettle or
your pot or whatever right on top and
you can cook off this thing the real
benefit of these rocket stoves is that
they're just so darn efficient so if
you're in a place or a situation where
you can't get your hands on large
quantities of firewood then build a
rocket stove all right next i'm going to
show you how to use a pair of pliers and
some baling wire to make a rocket stove
out of a pile of wood first things first
take a nice long piece of baling wire
lay it down on the ground in front of
you and start stacking
some wood on top of it you want these as
tight as you can together you're gonna
take one small smooth piece of
wood and you're going to fit it right in
the heart of it all right you want this
as tight as possible
so we got a nice tight bundle of logs
there
then
you're gonna do
is take that middle piece and pull it
out
got a nice hole right there in the
middle and we're gonna go
okay
all right so we've got the bundle of
logs with the hole for the vertical
chimney in the middle
we've got airflow on the bottom
and just take another log
lay it right there and now we have
something to rest a stove or kettle on
look at that that went from 0 to 60 so
quick you know depending on how much
airflow you have between the gaps you
can go ahead and put that down and often
it doesn't make a difference this rocket
stove is not as efficient and not as
useful for cooking as the other rocket
stoves i showed you but it uses the
principles of rocket stoves to allow you
to ignite a lot of logs very quickly
using very little kindling so it's a
great way to start a fire if you like
this sort of thing you might want to
check out swedish torches which is a way
of taking a wood round chopping it up
then putting it back together and
building a fire in the middle this is
just kind of more of a redneck version
of a swedish torch
well hopefully you guys enjoyed learning
about rocket stoves and how to make them
if you want to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we have
over 200 videos on our channel right now
including 14 ways to start a fire
without matches 24 best campfire recipes
my favorite knots and how to tie them
there's a little something for everyone
and you may not know this but i have
another channel that's even bigger the
catfish and carp youtube channel with
over 600 videos about fishing and so if
you want to see that i'll put a link in
the description as well so don't forget
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
you've got so many boogers